nos piden calcula el número de moles en
una muestra de glucosa ce 6 h 12 ó 6 cm
1.52 kilogramos
como siempre pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrar lo que nos piden por tu cuenta
y esta tabla periódica de los elementos
nos resultará útil
muy bien ahora si estamos intentando
encontrar el número de moles recuerda
podemos pensar aún mol como una cierta
cantidad de algo si digo una docena de
algo pensamos que son dos unidades de
ese algo por su parte si decimos un
molde algo debemos pensar en el número
de avogadro de ese algo sabemos que
tenemos 1.52 kilogramos de nuestra
molécula en cuestión es decir de glucosa
entonces busquemos la masa por mol u
otra forma de pensarlo es buscar la masa
molar de la glucosa y una vez que la
tengamos podremos dividir la masa de la
muestra entre la masa por mol con eso
obtendremos la cantidad de moles que nos
preguntan entonces cuál es la masa molar
de la glucosa bueno para encontrarla y
por esto es útil esta tabla periódica
necesitamos encontrar la masa molar de
los elementos que la constituyen
primero nos vamos a fijar en el carbono
podemos ver en esta tabla periódica que
el carbono tiene una masa molar de 12.01
gramos por mol como hemos mencionado en
otros vídeos podemos ver este 12.01 como
la masa atómica relativa de un átomo de
carbono como la masa atómica promedio de
un átomo de carbono o lo que es muy útil
y por lo que es valioso el número de
avogadro es que si tenemos el número de
avogadro de los átomos de carbono éstos
tendrán una masa de 12.01 gramos
entonces podemos decir que el carbono
tiene una masa molar de 12.01 gramos por
mol
ahora podemos hacer lo mismo para el
hidrógeno el hidrógeno tiene una masa
molar de 1.008 gramos por mol por último
pero no por eso menos importante tenemos
al oxígeno podemos ver en la tabla
periódica de los elementos que tiene una
masa molar de 16.00 gramos por mol bien
ahora tenemos toda la información que
necesitamos de nuestra tabla periódica
la masa molar de la glucosa será 6 veces
la masa molar del carbono más 12 veces
la masa molar del hidrógeno más 6 veces
la masa molar del oxígeno entonces será
6 por 12.01 gramos por mol más 12 por
1.000 8 gramos por mol más y cada
molécula de glucosa tiene 6 oxígenos
entonces tenemos más 6 por 16.000 gramos
por mol
12.01 + 12
1.008 más 6 por 16 es igual
y bueno si estamos pensando en cifras
significativas podemos ver que la masa
molar del hidrógeno está escrito hasta
el lugar de los milésimos por su parte
el carbono y el oxígeno están escritos
hasta el lugar de los centésimos al
sumarlos debemos redondear hasta el
lugar de los centésimos entonces tenemos
180 puntos 16 entonces esto será
aproximadamente igual a 180 puntos 16
gramos por mol y podemos decir que estos
son los gramos de la glucosa 66 h 12 o 6
por mol de glucosa de 6 h 12 o 6 ahora
podemos usar estos 1.52 kilogramos para
encontrar la cantidad de moles que nos
piden si empezamos con 1.52 kilogramos
de glucosa 66 h 12 o 6 primero vamos a
convertirlo en gramos porque aquí
nuestra masa molar está dada en gramos
entonces por y tendremos a los gramos en
el numerador ya los kilogramos en el
denominador cuántos gramos hay en un
kilogramo bueno tenemos 1000 gramos por
cada kilogramo podemos observar que si
ahora multiplicamos estos dos se
cancelarán los kilogramos y obtendremos
el número de gramos que tenemos de
glucosa que serán mil 520 gramos y ahora
que tenemos la masa en términos de
gramos podemos dividir esto entre
nuestra masa molar o lo que es lo mismo
multiplicarlo por la cantidad de moles
que hay por gramo es decir por cada
molde glucosa tenemos 180 puntos 16
gramos de glucosa
y esto nos dará bien tenemos 1.52 por
1000 es igual am y esto nos da el número
de gramos de glucosa que tenemos y luego
tenemos que dividir por 180 puntos 16
entre 180 puntos 16 y nos da este número
ahora si pensamos en las cifras
significativas tenemos 3 cifras
significativas por aquí tenemos 5 por
acá así que vamos a redondear lo a tres
cifras significativas entonces esto será
8.44 moles de glucosa nuestros
kilogramos se cancelan a los gramos de
glucosa se cancelan y nos quedaremos con
8.44 moles de glucosa
y hemos terminado